Chris yeah Karl in case you guys don't
know you've now work as security for a
nuclear bunker well we have to have some
kind of security clear that wait I
thought we were playing Minecraft no
we're defending a bunker from the 100
players right here and if they break in
they get $10,000 open the gates
do not let us see what one of them threw
away why do they get money for stealing
our secrets don't think too deep into it
if you keep asking questions I will have
to kill you I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm
sorry
also so we've done videos like this
before and I got a brand new command to
make this one more special oh man that
spawns creepers oh great bars Oh guys go
jump in the backline kill the people
that get through I know 10 grand sorry I
hope you don't like money think I killed
boy Jedi right at the end wait for it
wait for it now haha boom go there's so
many of them guys I'm leaning out the
numbers as much as I can how could you
guys not hold them off
we're holding all boys you know I get
out of here nice shirts you deserve to
die yes go minecraft Steve yay hey this
guy has shirts who skin No hey Jason
this is a picture too
I've got the caboose guys I've gotta
kinda ruin these people's day nope this
is the best thing I've ever done I just
killed everyone I want you guys all to
know that there hasn't been a guy that's
appeared in quite some time and I think
it's because you guys keep killing them
so much look every single person thanks
guys
guys the winner is getting 10 grand it's
not supposed to be easy five minutes
left in the first round oh yeah what am
i doing right here they can't s'more oh
you were gonna make it but now you're
not
looks like you Jimmy oh no I hit boy Jed
I don't know what I want to know what
why don't more people wear B skin
they know we're biased towards people
would be submerged yeah why don't they
just wear it it's like a free cheat code
memens Nadel
Oh No hey like look guys it's sands from
undertale don't you mean to say these
guys are in unison right here shame if I
did this Jimmy watch this oh hey Chris
you know we haven't done in a while
what's that our brand new creeper
command wait wait for it wait for it
wait for it oh there's four Jedi it'd be
a shame if I oh I got him don't worry
thank you thank you Chris watch this
let's try to let none pass let's try to
let nug pass bank robbery and the other
challenges they were too easy oh we all
x-games mode all of them I know is low
and Chris just did something bad because
nobody shows up to the ending part for
like five minutes I just deleted
everyone this is so much fun
no Chris look at me what do I look like
you look like you're just murdering look
at me look at me Oh hahaha
Jimmy it looks like you're doing
something not be G Oh round over that is
the end of round one we have two more
rounds left and $10,000 is on the line
good luck everybody also as of right now
Star Wars is great it's gonna win the 10
grand so if you guys want the 10 grand
you should do better you can no good so
like I just told the players this rounds
gonna be harder going going going
you only just join can all that going
Jimmy no they have families one of you
is getting ten grant and it's not
through that lava oh it got a sneeze hey
if you bounce that slime pin you don't
land right here and go through this
tunnel to this then you're screwed this
is much harder I have the creeper
command ready start round two five four
three two one
musica they got um they pull for a [ __ ]
they did Ginga dude they keep walking
near the middle why target practice hey
jerk - goodbye
sorry no 10 grand again for you it's
kind of cruel when you think about it
I'm playing target practice
but taking 10 grand away from people oh
when you say it like that it makes it
way more exciting oh I do I kill for a
don't worst guy is falling behind yeah
I'm not gonna lie I shot him twice is
anyone getting through anymore
apparently very weeding out the weak
those who can make it through will
survive we stand for Narnia Godspeed
except for those two people
I'm waiting inside this tunnel to just
wipe them if we're all watching this
side
wait who's I hey from downtown let's see
how many we could get from over here oh
yeah
target practice let's hold on with this
let's see if I can hit the guy
oh I'm hitting them from downtown ah oh
my gosh someone stopped me a crazy wolf
out of nowhere is in first place Lala
oh you think you're clever huh you think
you're clever the worst thing is I
usually work with big CN boy Jedi and
now I'm basically just about targeting
them the lava is burning the wool and
made a hole in the map oh my god
wait what's down here is there any way
this is healthy Jimmy I'm gonna make a
secret tunnel we didn't even plan this
for the lava / - all the wool okay I'm
gonna make a tunnel from the spawn we're
all making tunnels now there we go
that's a smart person tunnel right here
let's see if anyone finds it someone
found the smart person tunnel sorry bro
no secret tunnels here sorry hey bro
nobody's coming to my secrets everyone's
coming to mine and they're just
following ten seconds left guys oh
really I've been so focused on my town I
forgot finish it up strong yep let's run
some dreams real quick boys yay I love
ruining dreams alright that is the end
of round two bring the bush in here he
is in first place quite decent margin
wait why are all the people out I don't
know oh shoot oh shoot
how did everybody get down start know
there's people out secret oh no I made a
secret tunnel here wait Carl Carl I
totally forgot Carl hey big Bush welcome
to our chat you are ahead by alive what
is going through your mind I don't know
I have my sister and my mom right
sitting next to me I'm like sweating I'm
just really nervous if he does win the
$10,000 I want you to promise that
you'll never get mad at him for playing
too many video games again I promise my
daughter wants to just really say hi
really alright so first off we're
blocking this off okay I guess you watch
watch watch no no no no boom
look at that wizard Chris
okay start the third round let's do it
why are some of them going to the left
there's lava they're gonna give it an
honest try why are what are they doing
the right path is the only path I
blocked it off guys get out of here a
lot of people die and these guys are
trying to find secret tunnels there's
nothing there
gosh this is actually so petrifying so
they're all funneling get over here
let's see how many are making the dump
here's two now cats are terrified we
gotta pick up back up back up back up
back up guys back up back up back up
back up big ceeze about the past the
epic poem no way big ceeze in the lead
big ceeze climbing up the ladder he's
coming up the ladder big ceeze currently
in first place he's this guy right here
alright let's see you make the jump will
he make it will he make it well you make
it oh he's got this all day big same
right oh my gosh it's big see about to
win another 10 grand Oh epic Bush is now
in third it's so close
boy Jedi's coming up what just blew up
Big C just fell he fell yeah oh that's a
big fell into lava that's a big [ __ ]
see more like big mistake alright dad
big Bush is running up the ladder right
now he's going up there the epic Bush
hasn't scored it forever was oh no we
got pushed into lava II know in Star
Wars is great it's coming back John
where's this great if he scores right
here is gonna take the lead nope maybe
big C's right okay okay come on man if
he messes this Big C and Star Wars are
gonna got it got it got it got it got it
good all right he's got three minutes
left plenty of time to put some points
on the board here he's gonna get thirty
points bringing him back in the second
look at Big C epic bushes don't Wars are
great are all basically tied for first
well Big C made the deal makes it
flawlessly
oh he's good for 30 now two minutes left
it's basically tied what we're gonna do
is we're just gonna start breaking
random glass blocks like this alright
only the highest of the IQ will make it
through Oh Star Wars made it through Oh
did big sea foam Pixies right here here
he is
Oh
high IQ dude it's so good watchin these
kids follow these glasses just drop like
a little baby
I feel bad for Big C but at the end of
the day he should have sold there wasn't
a glass block am i right
oh the epic [ __ ] it's tied for first
oh oh
where's yet TV oh it's gorgeous a big
Bush is going up the ladder right now
alright he's got a oh he's on the ladder
he's coming up he knows where the glass
blocks are hopefully alright he's
dodging the blankets Oh Bush did he make
the jump alright it did will he make it
[Music]
that was probably the one that cost him
the ten thousand thirty seconds left so
Oh Big C could still come back to Star
Wars it's Star Wars his game to lose hi
here we go here so it's right here he's
currently in the lead he might eat this
for the epic poem is oh so out of time
wait aren't we typing Bush is about to
make the joke with 10 seconds left 10
seconds big scene oh no did he not make
it didn't make it no where's Vic
Seward's mixi there's Mick see Big Joe
no he didn't make it he didn't make it
oh no Big C Oh Big C was right here the
epic I feel so bad I died twice at the
very end
oh you guys seem like really nice people
so I wanted to give you guys five
thousand dollars as a consolation prize
no problem now the actual winner Star
Wars is great congratulations
Star Wars thank you I did not expect to
win I'm shaking well congratulations
make sure you viewers subscribe and
we'll see you in the next one